I I guess I I should start the year off
with a take all right what's your take
Connor all right so my take
um so I was at I was at that assembly's
house and he asked if I wanted some
anything to drink I was like yeah sure
I'll just I'll have some water so I'd
pour myself some water he's like what do
you no ice really I said yeah I like it
I like it less when it's cold so on my
tickets that I don't like cold water I
think that I think the room temperature
water is tastier is that it's easier to
drink that's my take for the year well
I've got no trash days when we're
starting off I've been holding this back
as we saw each other two days ago and I
really wanted to be like is this weird
I'm like this is not weird right we're
gonna be like in trash Trace 2024 and
we're gonna be like you know what
smiling overrated kind of I kind of like
I've just I just had this conversation
and he made me feel like I was weird for
liking water that was from straight from
the [ __ ] tap just just room ass
temperature I just want to be able to
drink it right then like if it's too
cold my mouth gets too cold and then my
my esophagus feels like it's freezing I
I just want to have the drink right away
sounds like a skill issue to Me Maybe it
issue is there a reason you just okay
yeah since since we're declaring war
against cold Wars I'm not against cold
water do I hate it when I'm in America
and they give me a cup of water and it
is 99 ice and one drop of water yeah I
hate that okay so like are you just like
a realized person no matter what I'm
like a one two Cube guy Max like I
wanted to like lightly cool the water
like I don't want to I don't want that
[ __ ] to be ice cold like lightly cool I
just wanna I want the illusion that I'm
cooling it without cooling it is it
possible that I just have a take that's
the same as you because I'm like no give
me all the [ __ ] ice just if if you're
going to show dogs if you're gonna put
this feels like an AI generated
conversation like a trash taste if
you're gonna put ice cube in it just
[ __ ] fill that [ __ ] up I don't want
one or two I want a high glass or
nothing man and on brand I'm just in a
position where I'm kind of just like
listen listen give me both bro this is
not that I don't both is fine I'm not
like I'm on the show it's like I just
did it and I got I felt attacked the
Titus was like how dare you not have
eyes three I don't care that much it's
just my Southeast Asian blood like it's
when when I when I because when we have
eyes there we need to fill that [ __ ] up
to the bridge because the ice melts so
quickly so I I've just got on your
customers
basically right basically okay here's
here's something even more outrageous
that Thailand does not Regis yeah
outrageous
sorry egregious sorry I I [ __ ] up the
words all the time we have like 900
questions okay you talk about putting
ice cubes in water right so here's what
they do in time I know you're gonna tell
me now I already hate it they uh serve
you the bit I know I know and then they
are with ice with ice in it and they
give you ice and some place and some
places have the ice already in the cup
where you pour the beer and it's why
it's because because of the weather okay
because of the western yeah because I
wanted get to the bottom of this is Thai
beer made or I guess like brewed in a
way where it's better cold or is it just
like any other beer where if you put it
with some [ __ ] ice cubes and it's
like what the [ __ ] it's kind of like any
other beer honestly
I'm gonna have to be like no that's not
allowed I was gonna give it the benefit
of the doubt if it was like brewed
differently where it's like oh it's
actually better surf chilled but like no
okay but here's the real question would
you what what which of the two evils
would you prefer a warm bear or a beer
with ice in it because you you ain't
getting you ain't getting a cold beer in
Thailand that like maintains itself okay
so you have two options you have two
options either you drink a warm beer or
you drink a beer with ice in it and I
shoot I like you and I'm gonna be honest
I choose the Ice Cube man I that to me
having a refreshing feeling with a beer
is the lesser of the two evils hold up
hold up hold up would you put ice cubes
in a glass of wine
yeah
because this is the same kind of
question right you're you're
compromising the drink obviously with
stuff like you know whiskey there's
there's arguments there and some people
say the water helps the flavor but with
beer that's flat out just no no no you
do not the you don't put water to be
fair I've never had warm beard nor beer
with ice probably yeah
when you're at college or something
right like you just forgot to put in the
fridge you're like all right well I'll
just take a warm beer what I mean is
that a wall it's like room temp yeah
okay room temp is a bit different to
warm well I mean how warm can it be I
mean yeah room temperature in Thailand
it's very different from room
temperature
you have a barbecue in the summer and it
gets you know the beer gets really warm
because you ran out of ice in the cooler
and it's like all right well you know
it's whatever warm beer is fine but
putting water in beer and Ice having
like dilute all of the beer that's water
down beer is a little bit nasty yeah as
if like Coors Light wasn't drinkable
like it wasn't like a [ __ ] what's the
word
um it's hard enough to drink some beers
why the [ __ ] would you want to put water
in it it's it's okay yeah I like I'm not
gonna defend this obviously because I
both are like awful in my mind but like
my Stratton Thailand is like if you if
you have let's say a glass full of ice
for example cools it down very quickly
so it doesn't get like too watered down
so you and since there's like less
volume you can drink it more quickly as
opposed to like letting it get watered
down I choose that evil over having warm
beer because there's just something
about I'm not like a fan of like warm
water in general unless it's kind of
like I'm Ill or something [ __ ] love
warm water just like this it reminds me
of tea
a lot of warm water is like watered down
to you I have occasionally just drank in
warm water yeah it's like [ __ ] it I just
wanna I want the feeling of tea without
having to make a tea I don't know why
I'm not too sure
it's close enough it's close enough I'm
not sure about that one
I have dog [ __ ] takes all right this is
my dog [ __ ] why don't they just okay
what I don't understand right is that
okay obviously it's hot outside right
yeah and you want to keep the beer as
cold as you possibly can yeah so why
don't they just do that thing where they
do in Japan where they just shove the
the beer like glass yeah in like a
freezer or something so that it's like
chilled out yeah I thought about it then
immediately pulled a beer and then if it
starts to get warm just [ __ ] naked
problem solved in Australia we don't
have to [ __ ] worry about it's hot as
[ __ ] in Australia by the glass shredders
in the go-to yeah extra that's just like
a lot of like fridge space though you
know that that's always storing all
those ice cubes I'm wondering how the
like Japan
it's like so optimized with space
because in most places like having like
a fridge full of glasses that's just
like that's just a fridge that you're
basically like not using for food or
otherwise I guess I mean let's just
let's break down the logistics here okay
okay you you let's say you're cooling
the drinks obviously they stay cooler
for longer that's the benefit yeah uh
you probably can't store all of your
drinks in a cooler though right like you
probably don't have a big enough thing
to put all the drinks if you're a
business selling drinks all day but
maybe the glass is cool quick enough or
you could just shove them in because
it's you know they fill up with ice yeah
so they don't take up that much room so
this maybe you can it can work I don't
know you can stack drinks right outside
like ages I feel like I don't know this
this is like a weird complex maybe I
feel like the bigger problem is is that
if you if you're giving glasses out to
everyone right like if you give a bottle
you sell it it's done yeah you don't
have to worry about getting it back
right if you if you give a drink with a
glass you have to get rid of the the
glass that you you know poured the beer
out of and then now you have to try and
get the beer glass back yeah and and
also every that also means everything's
so complicated in my head every time you
order it every time you order a new beer
you need a new cool glass with it right
I imagine most of it's cans as well
almost six bottles actually bottles or
glass bottles so there's it's uh
especially if you go to like the local
kind of you know bars and restaurants
they don't really have like beer on top
like single beer Singapore isn't good
enough that it like deserves to be on
top I'm gonna say that how loud okay
um it's kind of like it's it's mostly
just in like glass bottles so I mean if
they were why don't they just shove the
glass bottles in the freezer and then
you can just drink straight out of that
the freezer well you know in in a cool
environment so that it's frozen down so
that you can just drink directly rather
than pouring it into a glass just drink
it straight out of the bottle I think
problem is is that ice cubes are really
[ __ ] easy to make uh yeah but they
also take up space yeah but I think you
can you can make them pretty quickly and
I think maybe keeping glasses in a
fridge will take a while I think you can
this solution is that making a a [ __ ]
ton of ice cubes is easy yeah and that
keeping glasses cooled and stuff is
complicated it just doesn't seem like
intuitive in any way yeah I agree I mean
I feel like it's probably something
that's just that was that started and
then they just kept doing yeah yeah they
haven't thought I don't know I also I
don't know [ __ ] fridges are expensive
yep come on man what the [ __ ] come on I
don't know to me this is just like the
equivalent of being like Oh I'm gonna
make some ice cubes so I'm gonna take
some cold water and then boil it wait
till it cools down and then turn it into
ice cubes it's like kind of it's like
two steps in one where you can just go
straight to the one step yeah I guess I
mean get your [ __ ] together either way
I'm not excited for beer in Thailand
that's for sure
I'm gonna be like no ice please
how do I say no ice sorry how do I say
no ice most places in uh Thailand speak
English so oh okay all right especially
if like you're in Bangkok just be just
yeah just ask for no ice it's pretty
well they give you a weird look if you
say no wise no I think most tour like
most tourists go through this like
conundrum when I go to Thailand they
like why are they so stupid bro German
would [ __ ] drop dead dude
be like that you know that gif of Walter
White fall into the ground yeah when
he's like with his mouth open it'd be
that Germans when they go to Thailand
and get offered a beer with ice
[Laughter]
I think they would I think they would I
probably would I think I think War would
be declared Germany would re-millage for
us again they'd be like all right we
found a reason
does diners need ice with every glass of
water I think so yeah I think he refuses
to drink like water or is very picky at
least we've got to get them on we'll get
them on yeah I can grill out more about
this because I I felt like I felt
attacked you know is that an American
thing you think dude yeah they [ __ ]
love it because they love it remember
every single like uh restaurant or Diner
anything you go to you always get the
giant [ __ ] like two liter cup like
plastic cup with a straw and it's nice
it's not the ice it's not the big ice
cubes
yeah that's that's what that I sucks I
kind of like it no no one like the
saddest looking like the saddest looking
thing is with the shave dice I'm I'm a
I'm an advocate of if it's like the
shave like really small cubes it needs
to be up to like the brim otherwise like
when when you when you have like the uh
when you have a glass and it's just like
a little like one small layer of shaved
ice cream yeah that just it just looks
so sad for me that ice is doing nothing
I just don't use that ice because I'm
just if I like you know when you because
a lot of the time you go to the soda
machine and you do it and it's always
that shitty ice and you're like oh
you know I kind of wanted to like not
have my drink be immediately watered
down so I'm just not gonna put it but I
like crunching on them when you finish
it's nice
you guys are the monkey brains I I feel
like I'm Giga brain like I'm like third
eyeing this [ __ ] like no ice to me
please I don't know man how about two
how do you feel about you do I chew the
tea bag like
okay there's like there's like icy in
this hot tea how do you feel about
lukewarmt just look just like room
temperature tea and you know I mean
obviously it's a lukewarm tea is a tea
that has been left out yeah same with
coffee you know yeah you know it depends
on my mood I'd say 80 of the time I'll
just down it
because I'm like I'm not excited about
it because it's not even warm anymore
it's kind of room temp I'm like ah all
right
all right make another one that's that's
someone who's addicted to call it's like
it's like I will swallow my pride
because I need this in my voice tea
that's right yeah that's what the
British people conquered the world about
that's what they struggle for her
identity that's like I can't throw away
what they worked so hard for and ruined
the world for do you ever like reheat
coffee or reheat tea if it's like no no
you can't do that you don't have to do
that I'm not allowed to do that that's
not I sometimes do it sometimes
sometimes just like just like just like
20 seconds in the microwave
that hurts to hear that hurts to hear
it's weird because sometimes I'm okay
with doing that with coffee but I just
refused to with my tea I don't know why
weird mental thing yeah coffee it
doesn't work
coffee doesn't work no tea it works
coffee doesn't I don't like doing it
with tears at the Forbidden technique I
I think it works with coffee fine
I mean I don't let it get to that point
Italians are like Mamma Mia a microwave
and my coffee over here I mean look it's
like I don't know
I literally took me five minutes to
process I was like there's no way he
said that that's why it took me so long
what the [ __ ] to be fair 99 times out of
100 I don't let it get to that point I'm
drinking that [ __ ] while it's hot right
but sometimes you get a little bit busy
you know you might you know you might
have to go out for a little bit commit
to the iced coffee you put some [ __ ]
high you put some [ __ ] ice cubes in
it you don't [ __ ] try and turn it
back that's that's like it's like it's
like climate change we've gone too far
we can't we should just [ __ ] commit
let's just go full hellscape no I look I
look at it I pick it up and I feel it's
lukewarming I'm like I can fix you let's
just shove you in the microwave